it's feared reforms to America's
Affordable Care Act will hit women
hardest from a return to higher premiums
for women to gaps in coverage for birth
control and breast pumps the Republican
push to repeal the Obama era health care
is already raising concerns which or now
by dr. Mott Blair from the American
Academy of Family Physicians he's in
Kansas City good evening to you and tell
us first of all how the Affordable Care
Act changed the medical provisions for
women specifically thank you then it's a
pleasure to speak with you today we the
formal care act has really allowed for
access to the services that are really
important for women particularly
preventive services prenatal care and
ongoing a contraceptive issues
particularly as a good example and it's
considered what we call essential health
benefit which mandates that insurance
plans have to provide these coverages
for women and what was the situation
previously women were potentially facing
higher premiums that than men because of
specific needs oh absolutely said that
so there there is a thing that we call
parity now that means that women are not
penalized for being women in particular
and in in the states you know if you had
a pre-existing condition often times
your insurance could be denied based on
those grounds at all so what if you are
a woman who maybe has c-section or
perhaps you have been a victim of
domestic abuse your insurance could
potentially be denied which essentially
shut down your access to the care that
we really believe women deserve and what
are you hearing about possible changes
to the Affordable Care Act what what do
you believe the thoughts of the process
is in place that will change the actors
you know it now there certainly has been
a lot of political dialogue messaging
around the formal care act and it's no
secret that that the Republic
administration and focus in charge of
Congress have said forever that they're
going to appeal and
place Affordable Care Act or what's
colouring the state's Obamacare what the
plan is to come forward is we don't know
and one reason we are speaking out so
strongly is that we know that there are
things that need to be preserved
particularly these issues that wrap
around women that fit for them to get
the care of it is you're saying that you
actually don't have any detail and
you're you're not privy to how the act
might be repealed or how it might be
changed but what are your your greatest
fears well my private spheres is that is
that we will go back to pre Affordable
Care Act where people could not get the
care could not get the coverage where
you could be denied your care based on
pre-existing conditions where you
couldn't get preventative care you know
those guys think your children couldn't
have their preventive care visits we
don't know need to go back to that step
we women in our country i think has come
a long way I think there's a lot at
stake in the coming weeks and months in
the Washington DC so what are people in
your position other physicians other
doctors what are they doing to make
their concerns playing to the new
administration so that certain
organizations that represent primary
care medicine of the American Academy of
Pediatrics ourselves the American
Academy attending physicians there was
five different organizations we came
together it made a joint statement of
the things that we felt that were really
important specifically as it applies to
women's health care and that represented
over 500,000 of physicians across this
country who were making that statement
that we believe this needs to be
preserved and do you think it needs to
be preserved in its entirety or there
any areas in which you think
improvements could actually be made this
is always areas where you can can make
improvements and certainly the primary
area is what we don't want to do
backwards you know with princess and
during the portal Care Act we medicate
which takes care of our most vulnerable
citizens throughout the country it was
actually expanded in 31 different states
and that meant that there were 10
million people who were had coverage for
care where before they simply had no
coverage or access to care at all so we
do not want to go back and and it's
important to preserve and games that we
play I mean we obviously have a
completely different system here with
the National Health Service but those
two million that you're describing is
being vulnerable with having no care at
all no cover at all previously what what
did people like that do in the situation
of need of medical care you know so
surprising is the numbers 10 million the
surprising thing is that what happens is
those people you know I have access to
care so what happens in the states when
when you have no insurance no access to
carry no place to get care you show up
in the emergency departments of our
hospitals and oftentimes that's the
inner privatization resources and it's a
very expensive care and we can actually
do that in a much more efficient way
when you have a family doctor or a
medical home where you go and your
community and get care from your doctor
in your community and that's what
happens when you have a large volume of
people who are uninsured or have no
access ok good to speak to your doctor
mop Blair thank you for sharing your
expertise knowledge with us pursued me
thank you thank you for having us review